Bienvenidos a en 5 minutos donde
intentamos explicar de manera sencilla
asuntos complicados la muerte de maxa
aminí desató la furianirán mujeres
quemando sus velos y cortando su pelo
manifestantes incendiando autos de
patrulla y jóvenes lanzando piedras a la
policía la muerte de la joven de 22 años
el 16 de septiembre tras ser detenida
por agentes de la llamada policía de la
moral ha colmado la ira en medio de una
represión cada vez más intensa desde la
llegada en 2021 del presidente
ultraconservador Ibrahim Racing Cuál es
el código de vestimenta para las mujeres
en Irán Qué es y cómo opera la policía
de la moral y que castigos pueden
enfrentar las mujeres que nos sigan los
códigos de vestimenta mani fue detenida
al 13 de septiembre por lo que las
autoridades consideran no llevar la ropa
de forma correcta testigos aseguran que
fue golpeada en una patrulla de la
policía aunque las autoridades lo niegan
fue trasladada a un centro de
orientación a fueron llevadas muchas
mujeres para hacer lo que llaman
reeducadas sobre las reglas del país en
cuanto a la vestimenta femenina estando
en custodia policial cayó en coma y
murió tres días después la versión de
las autoridades Es que la joven murió de
un ataque al corazón pero su familia
asegura que a Minnie estaba sana al
conocerse su muerte el 16 de septiembre
muchos y muchas iraníes salieron a las
calles pidiendo justicia parada mini
culpando a la policía de su muerte en
las protestas que se han expandido por
varios países muchas mujeres han cortado
su pelo en público o han quemado sus
jillabs actos de desafío claro a las
autoridades y ya varios manifestantes y
policías han muerto en medio de una
feroz represión policial
país pasa por una crisis económica
causada en gran parte por las sanciones
internacionales que están asfixiando a
la sociedad con índices bajos de empleo
y pocas oportunidades para los jóvenes
en medio de esta situación la muerte de
amí fue nada más y nada menos que la
gota que colmó el vaso Cuál es el código
de vestimenta para las mujeres en Irán
las normas se introdujeron un poco
después de la revolución islámica de
1979 en 1981 se aprobó una ley para ser
obligatorio el uso del hillab que debe
cubrir todo el pelo de las mujeres
también les está prohibido llevar ropa
ajustada pantalones rasgados o atuendos
de colores brillantes en cuanto a los
hombres les está prohibido llevar
pantalones cortos y las camisetas de
manga cortas se reservan solamente para
los jóvenes en cuanto al cabello las
autoridades piden no llevar cortes de
pelo considerados excéntricos sin
embargo son las mujeres las que más
enfrentan el peso de la autoridad Y es
que para la clase dominante iraní el
velo también un elemento político tras
la revolución el líder supremo el
ayatolá Ali hizo del hillab un símbolo
de la República islámica al decir que
los velos de las mujeres representan la
muerte de los mártires Qué es la policía
de la moral su nombre es Que traduce en
Versa Patrulla de orientación islámica
heredera de otras patrullas similares y
fundada en 2005 bajo un mandato
ultraconservador las patrullas de la
policía de la moral están compuestas por
hombres y mujeres suelen estacionarse en
lugares públicos como centros
comerciales plazas y lugares en los que
los jóvenes suelen reunirse su misión es
hacer cumplir los códigos de vestimenta
y de conducta las mujeres detenidas son
llevadas a centros de reorientación
donde se les hace firmar documentos en
los que se comprometen a no repetir
aquello por lo que fueron detenidas tras
una clase de reeducación tras ello
llaman a sus familiares normalmente
hombres para que les lleven ropa
adecuada y las recojan durante el
mandato del actual presidente el
ultraconservador Ibrahim Racing el
patrullaje se ha redoblado entre los
castigos están multas el encarcelamiento
e incluso la flagelación las mujeres que
no cumplan las normas pueden ser
encarceladas hasta tres meses Naciones
Unidas ya ha reportado casos de mujeres
abofeteadas en la cara y golpeadas con
porras tras la muerte de aminy y
diversos países como Estados Unidos o
Italia y también las Naciones Unidas han
pedido una investigación independiente
estos llamados se han hecho eco en
políticos locales legisladores y
ministros han comenzado a cuestionar a
las patrullas y el presidente del
parlamento pidió una pesquisa del
organismo mientras el presidente risey
prometió determinar las causas de la
muerte de Amén pero un relajamiento de
las normas de vestimenta para las
mujeres parece difícil en el país donde
las autoridades religiosas han hecho del
jillap uno capilares de su teocracia por
el momento se ha restringido el acceso a
internet y cerrado redes sociales en
medio del estallido social y la brutal
represión de las autoridades no Da
señales de una mayor apertura si les
sirvió el vídeo para entender Por qué la
muerte de maxa Mini sacude a Irán los
esperamos en otro episodio de en 5
minutos en France 24 y France 24.com